>> Sean: LIKE WE HAVE BEEN
EXPOSING AND TELLING YOU
JOE BIDEN TOTALLY SURRENDERED
HIS AGENDA TO THE RADICAL SQUAD
LEFT LIKE AMERICAN ENERGY JOBS
CRUSHED AND KILLED AND JUST GONE
WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN OPENING
UP THE BORDER, SUPPORTING D.C.
STATEHOOD, DEMONIZING POLICE
OFFICERS, PACKING THE COURT AND
NOT STANDING IN THE WAY FOR
CALLS TO ABOLISH THE SENATE
FILIBUSTER, BITE AND MAKING IT
VERY CLEAR HE WILL DO ANYTHING
AND EVERYTHING TO APPEASE THIS
EXTREME BASE AND HIS PARTY.
BUT DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT,
YOU CAN LISTEN TO THE LEADER OF
THE ENTIRE MOVEMENT,
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ IS
SAYING BIDEN IS NOW EXCEEDING
EVEN HER EXPECTATIONS, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> I DO THINK THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, PRESIDENT BIDEN
HAS DEFINITELY EXCEEDED
EXPECTATIONS THAT PROGRESSIVES
HAD.
I'LL BE FRANK, I THINK A LOT OF
US EXPECTED AND MUCH MORE
CONSERVATIVE ADMINISTRATION AND
I THINK NOT ONLY WHAT HAS
ULTIMATELY COME OUT, BUT THE
ACTIVE INVITATION AND
WILLINGNESS AND COLLABORATION
WITH PROGRESSIVES IN HIS FIRST
100 DAYS FOR ALMOST 100 DAYS HAS
BEEN VERY IMPRESSIVE.
>> Sean: IT'S NOW MORE CLEAR
THAN EVER JOE BIDEN DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT UNITY, THAT WAS A BIG LIE,
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
BIPARTISANSHIP, HE ONLY CARES
ABOUT HAVING POWER IN PERPETUITY
AND AVOIDING ALL ACCOUNTABILITY
IF HE IS EVEN AWARE OF WHAT DAY
OF THE WEEK IT IS.
AS KEVIN McCARTHY TWEETED OUT,
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN'S FIRST 100
DAYS, HE IS FULL COMPLETE BAIT
AND SWITCH, THE BETAS HE
PROMISED TO GOVERN WITH UNITY
AND BIPARTISANSHIP.
THE SWITCH, HE IS GOVERNED AS A
RADICAL SOCIALIST
GREEN NEW DEAL.
AND OF COURSE WITH BIDENS
SYCOPHANTIC ALLIES AND THE MEDIA
MOB DON'T WANT TO HEAR THIS.
WASHINGTON COMPOST ACTUALLY
ANNOUNCE THAT AFTER 100 DAYS,
GOING TO SHUT DOWN THEIR BITE IN
FACT-CHECK DATABASE.
WHY FACT-CHECKED AND WHEN WE
JUST ECHO EVERYTHING HE SAYS AND
WE SUPPORT HIM AND WE ARE JUST
PROPAGANDA FOR HIM?
THERE WITH REACTION,
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
BY THE WAY, IF SOMEONE DONATES
TO SOME WEB SITE OF YOURS FOR
EVEN A DOLLAR, THEY GET A SHOT
AT PLAYING GOLF WITH YOU AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
MY CAMPAIGN IS GOING TO AUCTION
A SPOT OFF TO PLAY IN THIS
TOURNAMENT, YOU HAVE LUNCH,
BREAKFAST WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP,
YOU GET A PHOTO, YOU PLAY AT HIS
GOLF COURSE IN FLORIDA, IT'S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF FUN, GO
ONLINE, LINDSEY GRAHAM.COM,
MAKE A DONATION, WHATEVER YOU
CAN AFFORD, BUT YOUR NAME IN THE
HAT, GOING TO PICK A WINNER SOON
AND YOU GET AN ALL EXPENSE PAID
TRIP TO FLORIDA TO PLAY
GOLF WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND WE ARE GOING
TO ENJOY PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
COMPANY WITH THE MONEY IS GOING
TO BE USED TO TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE AND TAKE BACK THE SENATE
SO IF YOU ARE OUT THERE
WONDERING WHAT YOU CAN DO TO
HELP >> Greg: ENTER THIS
THIS WILL BE SO WE CAN HELP THE
SLIDES TO SOCIALISM.
>> Sean: TO ME, IT'S SIMPLE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS TO BE
THE PARTY OF LIBERTY, FREEDOM,
THE CONSTITUTION, HAS TO BE THE
PARTY OF LAW AND ORDER, THE
PARTY OF EDUCATIONAL CHOICE, THE
PARTY OF CONSTITUTIONALISTS ON
THE BENCH, LOWER TAXES, LESS
BUREAUCRACY, SECURE BORDERS,
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE, PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH, TRUST AND
VERIFY AND FREE AND FAIR TRADE
AND FREE MARKET SOLUTIONS TO
HEALTH CARE THAT PROTECT
EXISTING CONDITIONS.
WHAT DO I MISS?
>> NOTHING.
IF WE DON'T WIN IN 2022, THEY
ARE DESTROYING OUR COUNTRY,
PEOPLE ARE DUMBFOUNDED ABOUT HOW
LIBERAL JOE BIDEN WON.
>> Sean: IT WILL BECAUSE THEY
WILL RUN THE COUNTRY, SOCIALISM,
WHATEVER MANIFESTATION REFORM
HAS FAILED.
>> SO HERE'S WHAT I'M TELLING
YOU, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WILL
WIN ON POLICY.
WE NEED GOOD CANDIDATES LIKE
HERSCHEL WALKER WHO HAS CREATED
A JOB, KNOWS HOW TO TALK TO THE
PEOPLE IN GEORGIA, PUT OUR BEST
TEAM ON THE FIELD, GET BEHIND
PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH AN AGENDA
JUST LIKE YOU DESCRIBED AND TAKE
THIS FIGHT TO EVERY STATE IN THE
NATION TO SAVE AMERICA WHILE WE
STILL CAN, I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE A BLOWOUT YEAR FOR
REPUBLICANS, THIS ELECTION IS
ABOUT POLICY, WE ARE GOING TO
WIN.
>> Sean: I WILL HAVE HELP IF
REPUBLICANS ARE SMART, THAT'S
THE MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
AGENDA, THAT THE CONSERVATIVE
AGENDA.
IF NOW THIS IS A BELLWETHER
YEAR, YOU WERE RIGHT ABOUT THE
HOUSE FIVE SEATS AWAY.
IN THE SENATE, YOU CAN'T HAVE A
BIGGER BELLWETHER.
FLORIDA, GEORGIA,
NORTH CAROLINA, NEW HAMPSHIRE
REALLY HATE RON JOHNSON, TRYING
TO CRUSH HIM, WISCONSIN, THEN
YOU HAD OHIO, THEN YOU HAD
ARIZONA, CAN YOU HAVE A BETTER
BELLWETHER THAN THOSE SENATE
RACES?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> I'VE EVER SEEN BETTER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY TO COME ROARING BACK THAN
I DID SINCE 1994.
HE THINKS THIS IS A BETTER YEAR
FOR REPUBLICANS BECAUSE THE
AGENDA OF JOE BIDEN AND AOC IS
ANTI-AMERICAN AT EVERY OF THE
AGENDA FROM THE ECONOMY TO
BORDER SECURITY TO BORDER POLICY
DECLARING WAR ON THE COPS, WE
ARE SET TO COME BACK, LET'S GET
GOOD CANDIDATES, PUT YOUR NAME
IN THE HAT, RAISE MONEY, AND
BEAT THESE PEOPLE'S WE CAN TAKE
OUR COUNTRY BACK.
>> Sean: WHY DID I THINK
DONALD TRUMP CRASHES YOU ON THE
GOLF COURSE?
JUST GUESSING.
>> BECAUSE HE IS BETTER THAN I
AM.
>> Sean: I DON'T HAVE TIME FOR
THAT, I LOVE NO TIME FOR GOLF IN
MY LIFE.
WAIT TO S